de nuevo afganistán les pertenece pero
qué tipo de régimen aplicará el talibán
esta vez muchos temen el regreso de una
dictadura religiosa de corte extremo y
así lo sugiere el nombre que los
talibanes eligieron para su actual reino
el emirato islámico de afganistán el
mismo título de hace 20 años durante sus
cinco años en el poder desde 1996 los
talibanes aplicaron la estricta ley
sharia que incluía ejecuciones y azotes
en público con una prohibición de empleo
y educación para las mujeres en esta
ocasión los talibanes muestran una
imagen más moderada
formaremos un gobierno islámico afgano
fundado en la inclusión y nuestra
política es que las mujeres tengan
acceso a la educación y el trabajo deben
llevar 'hiyab' por supuesto
tienen apoyo los talibanes su toma fue
bienvenida por una parte de la población
cansada de la presencia de tropas
estadounidenses y la corrupción del
anterior gobierno también tienen aliados
en los últimos meses estos rebeldes han
establecido de nexos diplomáticos con
irán rusia y especialmente con china
beijing de hecho confía en tener buenas
relaciones con el régimen
cocina tiene varios negocios sobre todo
minerales y materias primas que están
muy establecidos en el país su meta es
terminar la ruta de la seda a su vez en
el futuro existe un peligro para que
afganistán vuelva a convertirse en un
paraíso para el terrorismo los gobiernos
occidentales temen que haya una nueva
ola de ataques terroristas en el
extranjero el talibán es enemigo del
grupo estado islámico pero tienen
cercanía con al qaeda sin embargo ahora
alcanzaron un acuerdo con estados unidos
para permitir a washington la retirada
de sus tropas a cambio de garantías de
seguridad frente al ala más radical del
islamismo el punto clave del acuerdo
entre eeuu y el talibán es les
entregamos el poder a cambio que no
permitan que al qaeda organice un ataque
contra nosotros ese fue el pacto
original pero tendremos que esperar para
ver si eso se mantiene en el futuro los
expertos de la inteligencia de eeuu no
creen que los grupos terroristas planten
una amenaza inmediata para occidente
desde afganistán pero detenerlos a largo
plazo podría ser más difícil